ich habe ein goldenes turku ist sie dann
fliegt es fliegt kommt zu minecraft hero
dem schläger
und wir sind immer noch mit dem crafter
zu sammeln
meine lieben kinder bei der kef möchte
ich mich jetzt mal ein bisschen farbe
hier warum etwas mexikos meine schulden
und verzaubert also dass und ein logo
macht das einfach mal ich habe zurzeit
meine fifa komplett aus soll theater und
mein schwert habe ich auf an rating 35
noch back 1 2 spd 1 nr die drei focus 1
und 2 1 und ich finde wir haben
eigentlich geilsten abfalle musste ich
nicht wirklich nur die allerletzte folge
bei stadt roth dort habe ich mit bond ja
nicht natürlich nicht in drin land schön
außerhalb dass die wir irgendwie hin
locken wollen ägypten wieder an
pac man eben mal kurz ein paar sachen in
münchen einfach ehrlich was könnt ihr
dann schreiben sie ruhig bleiben muss so
sehen aber mit wegs forderte automatisch
gemacht kannst du okay gut so das kommt
alles daran machen
die skate park immer wieder hier rein
erzählt weiter was man noch machen
wobei ich glaube du genau wenn ihr mit
jason ritter in der folge von irgendwem
anders sieht dann müsst ihr den mini
kommentare schreiben
käfer hier mit luca augen fördert
schreiben schreibt schreibt luca
schreibt luca konkreter ist schreibt
luca von luca weil sonst würdet ihr auch
l p midcap schreiben kerner schlug aber
nur wenn ihn einer sieht so nicht nur
männlich sehen will nicht sagen ja die
haben mütter da und tages bauen weil das
ist dann wissen die das system bestimmt
dass er stimmt diese folge kommt auch
einfach später zehn grad vor damit hier
auf
real life und so an sich reißen nicht ab
vom pc verbringen müssen
wir sind echt statt bloß die stadt immer
blau ist wirklich so wie sie immer blau
auch in der konfis lasst doch am ersten
neuer könig oder was sagst du definitiv
wieder wendiger fahrkarte hat sein
witzig bei uns sondern sehr lustig die
ganzen rückweg wird dieser rucksack das
nix drin
die spiegel nehme ich immer mit mir
fehlt nur noch fehler vorliegen auf den
schuhen
wobei wir ja gerade schaufel ist fast
kaputt alter davor gleich gar nicht mehr
auf welchen schuhen auf den skates
schuhen
ich habe doch meine fehler macht doch
klar die feder finde ich auch viel viel
besser als ich habe hier protection
teams täter ist alles was spiel auf
angehen was soll ich mit dem rift blade
damit kannst du dich manchmal retten der
gegnerischen stadt bist könntest du
einfach so ruft portal machen und was
bringt name fantastischen welt weg
bringen was bringt ein verzaubertes brot
das halt ich folgt komplett voll
deswegen goldene apfel quasi nee das
halt deine nahrung slice bekommt ihn
voll
ach so findest du in der stadt
ich hasste dass die die stadt sollte
echt so wir müssen das so richtig heftig
bei uns richtig
ich will auch die wege sind zwar schön
aber am besten alles so strikt und
gerade so richtig schön dass wir sind
eine ganz gut ja aber so was macht aber
was ist hier mal einfach so groß
wettkampfs anwesen das raise me up und
revista fww weit seltener an die das war
brockenhaus das ist eine schande
genaueres sagen wir müssen alles
abreißen nichts bringt hier hinten da
wollte auch so etwas hier damals auf
brauchen fans ja noch altes irgendwo
also ich muss mal was wissen dass man
jedoch jünger oder was was macht das was
diesen kennst du diesen effekt wenn mir
übel ist dass es so dreht der bildschirm
walter giller
ich hab sogar daten die das machen
weiter im kampf machen sogar
wirtschaftsverfahren gegen welche
wertvollen senkt das war ohne zu gucken
klingt das dass das japan aus lohne bist
du dann habe ich gesagt ja ich habe es
genau damit
ich will ja noch richtig nicht unerlaubt
sachen indem es das ist trocknet fans ja
das ist wirklich heißt wir können uns
die sachen nehmen die sind ja nicht mehr
in unserer stadt ja klar da ist auch so
also wird man sagen gehört diese
diamonds ist mir auf den kopf
kobalt wahrscheinlich kann ich gar nicht
anziehen die solltest du kriegen weil
die seine feinde sind gucken wollte
jetzt möchte und wirklich alles nehmen
können das ist doch von broken
fangflotte jetzt sein erzfeind cook
siehst du dir blog hier ja erstmal augen
zu vor sich conny ein pinguin ich möchte
einmal gucken möchte ich einmal schlag
also du wirst nicht wandelt sein das ist
klar aber wie viel schaden nicht
mitmache ok wahrscheinlich eher nicht so
viel werde
wieso habe ich nur eins zwei drei vier
fünf sehr hast doch bei mir 33 von 34
jährige das letzte aber nicht an du hast
fast nichts abgezogen bekommen das ja
leicht gut aber das einfach weiter ich
bin mir eigentlich sicher gehört das den
oder was ja das ist ja brocken vermisst
es jemanden prozentig weil der bttv
liste das heißt wir dürfen uns das
nehmen weil die nicht mehr bei uns in
der stadt wohnen jetzt hundertprozentig
sicher dass die das sind ja die waren
auf jeden fall meine nachbarn ich habe
hier sehr sehr oft drin gesehen das ist
der ist steht aber sda von babys und
wildes ja das sind die sachen aber
auf jeden fall sind julias aus ja auch
irgendwie da wir keine zwei häuser haben
die haben schon ein paar schöne sachen
öbb und blogger mehr angewiesen
das heißt das hier ist wie es zu diesen
alle kisten leer
vielleicht wohnt dreht doch da noch ein
bisschen drin sollte was noch nicht
abreißen das habe ich mir schon die
german jazz abgezogen soll er sich
melden wenn aber mir ist gas drehen ich
brauche vier gas trainers zu gast rennen
für mich
gorgast sie übertrieben schnell zu
kriegen hast du welche mit den gästen
angeboten bekäme unterstütze dich doch
mal gibt mir auf alle 20 grad drehen was
für 20 euro 4
ich habe keine vier warte doch nur 20
nur 20 ich habe keine titel ist geld
geben
nein ich will ja männer phoenix fehler
machen
ach so wollten ja noch den links darf
als ghana fan eine gaswaffe level um
strümpel mein bike sport ist auch wieder
weg das ist richtig traurig die tropics
fonds oder nicht ja nee also ich brauche
auf jeden fall mein weg soll wieder man
ich hasse das mancher sonst irgendwie
kaputt macht ins meer aus findet ihr es
eigentlich besser ohne shader mit china
schreibt mir das nahe jetzt weiß ich was
ich vergessen habe auf meinem an die
focus 2 habe ich drauf hast du auch
fokus auf seiner waffe gezaubert ja dass
nämlich immer du kannst ein erschlagen
damit du hast so ich brauche jetzt hier
mein turm auf jeden fall weiter oder ich
lass mal kurz mal schlafen ja mit
geräten ausgeht schnell weiß wird gleich
wieder tag haben drin
und genau deswegen auf der funk alter
geschrieben
im november hat der regen auch das
mitgekriegt ohne shader sieht das so
heftig eklig aus irgendwie alles ja ich
habe mir auch schon übel seinen keller
gewöhnt also ich werde auch nicht mehr
ohne shader spielen vielleicht im kampf
hätte ich den mal raus machen ja genau
weiß dass man es sieht einfach so nicht
mehr nicht mehr so ansehnlich noch nie
hat nicht mehr so schön aus irgendwie
herstellen
man hat sich so den shader gewöhnt und
ohne scheu das spiel das nicht mehr
minecraft ist irgendwie ne wo du dir
recht geben
ich hatte hier darf nichts darf ja gut
ich mache mir nur electric zauberstäbe
daraus eine kiste voll und vielleicht
noch ein paar sind wegmarken stufe zwei
pausen und fünf electric stawski
vertraulich jetzt erstmal alle weil das
ist ja kostenlos zaubert dem fall
verfolgt verfolgen ja verfolgen
ich brauche ein elektromeister electric
ist hanson alter ich habe gerade alle
meine zu elektrik stars gemacht
ja also auch ich war alex klaws was du
ja wir könnten von mir ich hab nur ein
und ich hab' ich soviel eigentlich und
ich habe einfach keine ich habe jetzt
sieben hier der weg zum friedhof muss
noch gemacht wenn es sich jetzt einfach
mal ja ich glaube ich werde die nächsten
folgen aber ein bisschen was hier für
die allgemeinheit tun und mein haus
erstmal erstmal ein bisschen schöner
baum so dass das zum stil der stadt
passt ja aber da muss ich sagen da ist
und die stadt ganz ganz vorne wenn es um
allgemeine trinken geht sorbet baut ein
bisschen was für die stadt tun willst
was für die stadt bauen
ich habe jetzt eine mob falle für alle
gebaut ok wird natürlich das andere dann
weggegangen sind einfach die verbissen
sich einfach so brauchen fans und soja
sogar die stadt finde ich kacke
normalerweise muss man sagen ja dann tut
auch was für die stadt damit diese
besser findet nur aber nein wir wollen
jetzt nicht mehr hätten ist deren
entscheidung wenn die gegenwart nur ein
bisschen komisch so crazy warum ich hier
jetzt einfach mal ran nicht versetzt das
einfach mal so was ja so kaka aussehen
das so ist
naja kann der weg bei sich dann später
darum kümmern
live darfst du ich damals das ist
richtig eine fake fassade guck dir das
an was los das ist doch fake fur mir ja
ich bin auf den weg ich habe meine
sachen ausgeleert jemand hier so
scheinheilig von wegen
ja hier forscht am bau ist das der weg
gemacht ist hier nichts das ist doch
vorschlag das ist nicht stabiler
stadtmauer die fundamentalisten wir
dafür sorgen dass es walkers wort
verboten wird und dann machen wir die
stadt komplett aus obsidian komplett in
so eine coole eigene beleuchtung und so
weit so gut
warum die toten angemessen zu bestatten
habe ich ja eingepackt damit ich
eigentlich bleiben ist man von mir
eigentlich ein grabstein diesen übels
viele vor mir controller start beim
anderen bacon crafter hier würde die
visa durch die beiträge unserer stadt
der kev der imster wieder ein locker ins
piano ja das war in meinem stream wo ich
dann blieb eingeloggt habe also nicht
wenige kritiker aber nur ich hab nur
geschrieben wollte sagen rabatt
überfielen am bug ich stress haben
server lag durch server da bin ich
gestorben
das solltet ihr noch mit sein damit sich
jetzt nicht so übertrieben feiern das
ist eklig ja dann haben sie haben
eigentlich keine chocobos mittlerweile
ja zombie meint wir dürfen uns zwei
nehmen weil zweiten ohne sattel
ok ich weiß nicht welche zwei gold sind
und ich wir brauchen auch erstmal sattel
oder ja also welches in gold hierbei
lösten damit sie stehen jedoch ablehnt
gib einfach turbo ein und dann dieses
blauen linke macht man das ist jeder
hobby alte wie kann man sich dann haben
wir einfach du musst ich weiß nicht muss
ich mich beinahe vor allem ich hab keine
ahnung vielleicht einfach mit schoko pda
oder irgendwie sowas brauchen war und
eine feder nicht übel slam weiteres
warum ich denn wikipedia genau sagte
richtig dringen machos optimale
weggeschmissen scheidung opstelten
tobias ist zwar wegschmeißt kommastellen
immer falle hier ab
du brauchst ja bei mir akademie ein
bisschen warm haben oft sind deswegen
muss man voll ausbauen wenn du gehst ja
aber ich habe ein bisschen angst vor
denen weil ich habe meinen kleibrink
export mehr
wir lassen hier gehe ich ganz schön weit
weg stellen besteht doch mal richtig nah
dran sehe ich nur so weit wie möglich an
die kante stehen genau
danke mandant ist zuerst die vorderkante
später weiter valencias wird man glaubte
der rostet das ist ein ultra hier
er ist gold läuft direkt weg zur listung
ja ich komme wieder
aber ich hab' motiv dies nicht so heftig
im kampf schauen wie ich mich heute vom
jahr nicht erträgt man das doch auch
doch doch doch doch der kriegt ein
bisschen näher kann der kleinen haus
nicht anzünden
ich hole ich warte laufwerk laufwerk ich
hoffe dass mein ellbogen größte media
protection sich auch gerade wo ist mein
liga wo ist mein verzauberter legia
bogen alter hast du den freunde schreibt
immer mit in die kommunale wo man abfall
um ein legia bogen ist quick change the
blackberries kaputt gemacht fasste sie
wo ist mein legia bogen der blöcke wo es
bei legia wo kämpfers zu den du musst
ihn haben
da hab ich ihn ja eigentlich war hab ich
hab irgendwann weiß prof minor league
rennen meiner liegt dem dings drin mal
ich hab mir denen außer denen die bogen
kiste reingetan in wege einleger wurde
unverzollte habe ich selber schon
eingepackt in die kiste da ja aber ich
habe einmal einen verzauberten
reingepackt das ist genau meine mit
infinity einbrechen wegwerfen salter
nein
in die indy bogen tour natürlich müssen
wir weg flexen com ag 3 ich habe schon
ein halbes leid ich schon wieso man
nicht halten kann
machst du außerdem soll ich machen der
knopf wurde abgesprengt faxe man ja das
ist wohl bewusst im april bewusst der
mod wenn wo ist der wusste woher hat ich
habe auf das wort eingesammelt deswegen
ich fleck zählt man alle mops weg hier
wo ist dieser penner hin alter ich finde
es nicht gut wenn man den klatschen dann
hat er einfach ab oder wie zu viele mops
da sind so war das nicht beim letzten
mal da sind dann muss der vorstand bei
mir sind immer weiter mops gespannt
läuft bei der kef was los wir haben das
schwert eingezogen oder das kaputt
gegangen
du hast auch rücken gegen wie du hast es
einfacher für mich doch mal wie hat es
auf den rücken läuft nicht im inventar
lamia zusammenrücken
ich hab's wirklich im insel habe ich
nicht leider hat ihn noch eingeschränkt
noch nicht wo ich werd massenstart
passen die mordfall aus macht
mittlerweile ja es aber so töten sie
sich gegenseitig das gut bist du noch
einer übrig um einen schoko durch wege
und zeit haben sporty dann trotzdem
nahmen die dann trotzdem suding
erfahrung wenn ich es gegenseitig klein
damit hole ich denn überhaupt ein ich
mir dann freue ich nicht golden über
verdammt habt penner die pforten sich
raus cap ist ja ein bisschen irgendwo
einer kiste habe ich das weiß auch was
eingehoben deshalb bitte komm schon
markiert doch jan immer einfach da schon
wieder so ein doofer verzauberte er mag
mich nicht denn der andere mag nicht
ganz so golden die sonne ins gesicht
hier ist hierzu ein doofer jetzt ein
skelett ich habe mehr angst vor den
skeletten hat vor den anderen spielern
hier aber es gut die töten sich
gegenseitig das ist gut
in der höhe nicht fressen ist bizarr wie
viel leben hat er denn da wahrscheinlich
hat sich schon lesen da gcm zombie wie
wenn er sich schon mit goldene saal
freundlich gemacht hat sich dann kann
ich endlich mal zu mir
es wird so sein sie müssen auf ihn
warten mit ihm aufnehmen
ja wir müssen nicht damit zusammen dass
er halt dieser oder ein soldat mindest
des players geht das risiko einer
stiftung soll mit diesen komischen
dingsda zu töten aber das ist normal
oder ist schnell tot
der denker wenn man allerdings hat wenn
man dort eigentlich getötet welchen boss
leugnet ich finde nicht wieder aber die
da drin hüllten sich alle gegenseitig
das ganz schön ich alter diesen platz
schaffen gut erachte ich muss erstmal
ein paar ein rein das land erst mal was
mit den kassen gegeben sondern es kommt
wieder flott gemacht haben schon wieder
gefasst gemacht außer jetzt hier den weg
zum friedhof zumindest schon mal
ausgehoben es los mit diesem mit diesem
chocobos die alter die könnte gehen dem
golden gesund an
hoch die beine blonde puppe ruft immer
normales normales pisa läuft oder contra
ich hab ein
wo also ich mach den aber auf ok 3.0 ist
das
hahaha ich will mich auf dich drauf
setzen so hammann sattel
ich mache ihn unruhig habe ein goldenes
tokyo ist sie da jetzt fliegt es fliegt
express fliegt ja geil was wir
vorgeschlagen und vom spiel sie dann ja
sieht wann und wieso sie bedingen sie
dann alter weswegen er hat schon zu
minecraft euro' geschafft sagt hopf los
alter opa alter unserer stadt von oben
richtig geil aus man umgeht das echt fit
aber geilmann goldmann das kann fliegen
das ist richtig
also meine heißt ich pack das jetzt erst
mal ganz kurz hier auf meinem dach also
meine hallo mein name nicht
jetzt mache ich mir nämlich findet eben
die bäume hier ab da mache ich mir nicht
meinte kroos stahl hin was los meiner
heißt jacko sakko ist ein schoko wo er
von oben discovery so schön aufgeteilt
ist wir haben eine farm und mir hat
jemand so ein gangster gebaut und nun ja
ich glaube das war auch zum bild will
ich mal sagen dann der einfach alles
macht dann schön weg gebaut schönstatt
mordfall ist ein muss als nur noch einen
satz vorbei da kein dach ein
sie ist dass man anderer blog als medien
haben meiner leuchtet wie sex hier sieht
das hat sich buck kurz die sachen ihre
eigentliche einsammeln meiner leuchtet
richtig ist ein richtiger live blog was
haben die denn fünffachen da das soll
sich jetzt ein schoko opel lieber und
dass wir die folge beenden müssen
aber es stimmt ja freundlich entleeren
auch hier eben kurz meine taschen gott
bringt jetzt nichts hat der versorgung
ist auch egal
die marktfrau es aus die mobs töten sich
gegenseitig meine lieben freunde in der
nächsten folge werde ich meine taschen
bisschen mehr sortieren
ich war dort wieder ich werde ja
explosion wir sind jetzt mit dem kampf
könnte sich ben
rösler wusste ja wohin damit wird der
teppich voller zauber des links schwert
erwarte ich sie kaum eine andere
richtung
hier und da vielleicht alles schon
wieder zwei holz hier gefressen wenn man
wirklich jung kaputt der jacko du bist
tot gestorben ist
ich glaub ich spinne
wo hat man jetzt schon langsam wenn man
die früchte nicht einmal dass alle ist
so langsam an das ist auch aus wunderbar
leute dann sehen wir uns in der nächsten
folge gefallen im nächsten jahr anders
aufzunehmen nicht weil ich kaum kräfte
oder luca nicht liebe sondern auch bei
den auswechslungen bleibt und wieder
alleine aufgenommen weil ich ja die
weihnachtszeit pro produzierte von mir
noch ich werde nächste folge meinen
chocobos teil machen und noch meine
sachen weiter verzaubern eine rüstung
ist so dass ich dann krieg bar wo werde
ich vergessen und das tut sie alles
machen was richten der bridgestone aus
mob falle an ist redstone aus ist die
mob falle an ist redstone an ist immer
falle aus das heißt wir ganze zeit an
grüne das ist mit wenig besser
gewordenen ins geld wenn kein nachschub
von oben kommt nur irgendein freuen
würde ich sagen hallo wir sind beim
nächsten mal wieder macht und ciao